après avoir écumé les banques
hollandaise italienne obèses le gang des
mercedes vient d'entrer en france deux
mondes ordre à cette mission sérénité à
s'attarder à savoir comment on met un
véritable interrogatoire
non non ouais vas tu vas venir voir
quand même efficacité
lequel d'entre vous est dénommée cruiser
s'il vous plaît c'est comme le port
salut c'est marqué dessus
j'ai donc décidé de baptiser cette
opération vous inquiétez pas ça sera pas
long l'opération zen
j'ai identifié la voiture
je répète on note j'ai identifié la
voiture du complice
la manipulation c'est pas très grave ça
fait une plombe qui sont partis à
booster ie10 les villes le garage a plus
personne
ah ouais ils sont plus là ah ouais je
vois plus la voix des interrogatoires et
ça se passe toujours comme ça où là
c'était juste pour moi pour me faire
plaisir à mes noms d'habitude je pose au
moins une question là